- Well, I think
something really big
that's different
is Donald Trump.
Because in 2016 he was
running as an outsider.
He said, look, I don't have
50 years of political baggage.
I'm not paying back favors.
I'm an outsider,
I'm a businessman.
I know how to balance a budget,
I know how to cut spending
and I know how to, you know,
get stuff done basically
and I'll bring the troops home.
And so that's why the
polls got it wrong because
people voted for him
who had never voted
or who hadn't voted for 20 years
and so
now
it's four years later
and we can see that
he's acted pretty much
like all the
professional politicians
that he's increased the deficit,
he's increased the debt,
still hasn't brought
the troops home.
So now I think that
maybe people will say,
you know, maybe republicans
are beyond hope.
(upbeat music)
I'm Dave Rubin and this
is the Rubin report.
As always guys, don't forget
to subscribe to our channel
and click that pesky
notification bell.
And joining me today is a
senior lecturer in psychology
at Clemson university
and libertarian presidential
candidate, Jo Jorgensen,
welcome to the Rubin report.
- Oh, so glad to be here,
thanks for having me.
- Well, I'm thrilled to have you
and I know for sure that my
audience is thrilled to have you
because I've received
roughly 4 billion tweets
saying why haven't you
had Joe Jorgensen on?
So for the record,
we have been trying to make
this happen for a while
and we finally,
we finally did make it happen.
We weren't avoiding you and
you were not avoiding us.
Is that fair to say?
- It's just, you just
couldn't catch up to the bus,
back there chasing my bus.
(all laughing)
- You got a powered,
you got a super
powered bus over there.
Okay, so there's a lot of stuff
that I wanna talk to you about
and I think you know a bit about
my sort of political revolution
and probably most of
my political stances.
You may not know that
I actually did vote
for the libertarian candidate
in the last election.
I did vote for Gary Johnson.
I had Gary Johnson on my show.
I liked Gary Johnson.
I don't think he was,
you know, the strongest
libertarian candidate
in a year that there
was a moment for it.
So I guess my first question
that'll probably set
up everything else is
if it didn't work in 2016,
when so many people
were frustrated,
what is different this time?
Why should the libertarians
have hoped this time?
- Well, I think
something really big
that's different is Donald
Trump because in 2016,
he was running as an outsider.
He said, "Look, I don't have
50 years of political baggage.
I'm not paying back favors,
I'm an outsider,
I'm a businessman,
I know how to balance a budget,
I know how to cut spending
and I know how to, you know,
get stuff done basically
and I'll bring the troops home."
And so that's why the
polls got it wrong because
people voted for him
who had never voted
or who hadn't
voted for 20 years.
And so now it's four years
later and we can see that
he's acted pretty much like all
the professional politicians
that he's increased the deficit,
he's increased the debt,
still hasn't brought
the troops home.
So now I think that
maybe people will say,
you know maybe republicans
are beyond hope.
Now libertarians have known that
republicans are
beyond hope since 1971
and that's why the
party was formed
after Richard Nixon stopped
acting like a Republican
but maybe now the
Republican voters
and let me say, there are
many fine Republican voters
who want smaller government.
It's Republican politicians
who aren't giving it to them.
And so maybe after having
an outsider come in
a businessman who supposedly
can balance a budget
maybe they'll say, you know,
it's time for a real outsider.
- So what would you say
to the conservatives
or the republicans who
want smaller government,
they want lower taxes
and they're looking
and they're going,
okay, Trump did cut some taxes.
He got rid of some regulation.
We're clearly not going into
other wars at the moment.
We're bringing troops home,
that are basically looking
at that stuff and going,
Hey, Trump did give us a bunch
of the stuff that we want.
Yes, is the budget going up?
Yeah, but the budgets or
is the deficit going up?
Yeah, but it always
seems to go up.
Do you think he's
done anything right
from a libertarian perspective?
- Well, he has cut
some regulations.
However, I'd like to
point out that a tax cut
is also going to be possibly
an increase in spending
if they don't do
anything to make that up.
So
again,
the bottom line...
- Like the deficits are
going up either way.
- Yeah, exactly.
The bottom line is
spending's going up
and that's what counts.
Even if we're not
paying for it this year
we would be paying
for it next year,
10 years from now,
20 years from now
and that's what matters.
- Are you constantly
amazed as a libertarian
that telling people we want
you to keep more of your money
is not more of a winning ticket.
I mean, I think when
people really hear it,
if you bash them
over the head with it
over and over and over
again and you're like,
yeah, we want you to have
your money, not them.
I think they do get it,
but it seems like
it's such an easy sale
and yet for some reason people
just don't understand it
or don't absorb it.
- Yes, well, what
really frustrates me
are people like Bill Gates
or Oprah Winfrey who say,
yeah, the government doesn't
take enough of my money.
You know, text me more.
But look at what
Bill Gates does.
He starts the bill of
Melinda Gates Foundation,
does, you know, good work
and Oprah Winfrey
opens up her own school
right over in Africa.
Well, if they think
that the government
can do a better
job than they can,
why are they starting
their own foundations?
Why not simply turn
all of that money
over to the federal government?
And so I think that actions
speak louder than words.
And if even they aren't
turning their money over,
I think that that
just sent a message
to everybody else that,
Hey, the government
doesn't do a good job.
I can't think of much that the
government does a better job
than the private sector.
And I think that bill
Gates and Oprah Winfrey
and all these other liberals
who want bigger government,
I think that they're just
proving our point for us.
- So what do you think is
going on in their heads there?
Is it just,
is it misguidedness
or is it guilt
or is it that they know that
the machine and the media
will like them more if
they take these positions?
- I'm hoping it's ignorance.
The true sense of
the word ignorance.
Because a lot of people
just don't understand
how things work.
And that's one of the
biggest compliments
that I get from people
just, you know, non
libertarian friends
after they meet me,
they say, you know what?
I read the news differently now,
I look at things differently.
They don't, you know, for
instance, yeah, we cut taxes.
Okay, what about spending?
So you can look at things
in a superficial way
and think things are
going great without
you know, the understanding
or the underlying what's
going on beneath it all.
- Yeah, does the thing that
frustrates you the most
have anything to do with
the sort of simplistic way
we look at politics
where, you know,
half of the country
seems to think
that if you tell them they're
getting something for free,
they seem to think
it actually is free.
And combating that notion
is almost impossible.
You say free healthcare,
you say free education
you know, free money now,
literally free money.
It's like that combating, oh,
but you do have to pay for it.
That's just not what we
do publicly very well.
- Yes, I would have thought
that with the Obama phone,
remember those?
Basically what Obama was gonna
reach into his back pocket
and buy everybody a phone.
And that's what I've
been telling everybody
about these $1,200 checks
that they're getting,
is that money is
coming from somewhere.
And I know that, you know,
supposedly there was a hold up
because Donald Trump
wanted his name
written on the actual check.
Well, I don't think
that that check
is coming from his back pocket
or his private checking account,
it's coming from us.
So somehow they give us money
and make it, you know,
make it seem like it's a
Santa Claus or something.
But what's frustrating is
that they take our taxes
out, our income taxes
so that we get a tax refund
every year after April.
And so it looks like
we're getting something
and I wish they had never
started that practice.
I don't think we'd
be where we are now
if people actually
had to feel the pain.
And right now
people feel the pain
when they're teenagers and
then they quickly forget.
You know, so many times
I hear about somebody,
you know, a friend's
kid who goes to work
and like wait a minute, I
worked 20 hours this week.
Where's this money going?
And it's like, well, welcome
to the world of being an adult,
welcome to the world of taxes.
And so it feels painful then
but by the time you're
30, 40 years old
and it's grown and grown,
you've kind of
forgotten about it, so.
- Yeah, so I can't talk
to the libertarian
presidential candidate
without mentioning the
phrase that everyone says
that getting libertarians
agree on anything
is like hurting a bunch of cats.
And I think when people
think of the party,
the party itself,
they think of the naked
guy running on stage,
all the crazy characters
and everything else.
What do you think
the libertarians have
perhaps done wrong
if the ideas are right?
- Well, I think what we
all did wrong decades ago
was try to focus on philosophy.
Although I think the
libertarian party
pretty much had to do it
because when the party started
40 years ago we didn't have,
well, actually more than
40 years ago, 50 years ago,
we didn't have all
of these outlets.
We didn't have all
these educational groups
all of these research
institutions.
So we pretty much
had to do it all.
So we focused on philosophy.
And in fact,
it's interesting reading the
original libertarian papers
that talk about how we
shouldn't even run candidates.
You know we're a political party
and maybe not run candidates
because our job is to educate.
Well now we no longer
need to do that.
And so that's why I'm so
happy to be the candidate
and I'm really glad that I
was able to draw together,
both the pragmatic caucus
and the radical caucus
who somewhat agreed on me,
because what I'm trying to do
is I'm trying to give
a practical message
to the American public
and not talk about
cell ownership,
not talk about me but talk
about, okay, you know what?
You're having a hard
time paying your mortgage
because your healthcare
bills are so high
you know, or we hear about
people being sent off
around the world and you know,
your friends, your
neighbors your relatives
being killed in a senseless war.
So let's talk about things
that they care about
and take off our philosophy hat
and put on our political hat.
- Yeah, do you think that
there's a better chance
because of what you said earlier
that this is the year
to make the dent?
Because it seems to
me like there was,
in the summer
before the election,
there was suddenly this buzz
for a few weeks of like,
Oh maybe there's this
libertarian thing
that could happen.
Or at least, I mean, I
did a video in August
when I said that I'm gonna
vote for Gary Johnson
and I said, really
look, maybe he can't win
but I at least wanna
get the guy in a debate.
Now you did not
get in the debates.
So I'm guessing you're
not too happy about that.
But what about
combating the system?
Like, can you just talk
about what it's been like
to just combat the
two party thing?
- Oh, it's been
an uphill battle.
And what people
don't realize is,
well, one thing
that I hate is how
the libertarian party is put
as one of the other
third parties, right?
And I've been asked,
will you debate the
other third parties?
And my answer is no,
because we need to be
on the debate stage
with the democrats
and republicans.
We are the only political party
other than the Democrats
and Republicans
to have a presidential
on the ballot
and back to back
presidential elections.
You know, we have
joined the adult table
and that's the way we
need to be treated.
And it is frustrating
but of course
the Democrats and Republicans
they don't want us anywhere near
because we're going to show
that there is a
real alternative.
And we keep hearing
the media talk about,
talk about, you know,
two old, rich white guys.
And I would say, that's
not even the worst part.
The worst part is,
neither of whom is going to let
you make your own decisions.
Neither of whom is going to
let you spend your own money.
Neither of whom is going
to bring the troops home
and neither of whom is
going to do anything
about pushing healthcare costs.
And so I've been telling
people #fakedebates
because if we don't get
the message out there
then people aren't going
to see a real alternative.
Because there's really
not a big alternative.
You know, they create
a lot of fake drama
but they're both big government
people as we saw with Trump.
And so now we'll just have
to wait and see what happens.
And we hear the, you know,
the debate commission
who of course is made up of
half democrats, half republicans
you know, oh, it wouldn't
serve the American people.
You know, too many
people on stage
forgetting that, you
know, we saw what?
Nine Democrats on
the stage at a time
and they can't have
three or even four.
And also when you
look at the debates,
limiting it to two,
it's not there to help
the American people.
It's there to help the
democrat and republican party.
They truly do have
a monopoly on that.
- All right, so let's
back up for a second,
because you mentioned
that 50 years ago
there was this debate
whether the libertarians were
even to run at candidate.
So for some people that
are watching this right now
that don't fully get
what a libertarian is
can you do libertarian
101 and sort of
what is,
you know, the reason that it's
so hard to herd these cats
is when you talk to libertarians
there's always someone
that wants less government.
So you get it to less and
then someone says less
and then someone says
less and less and less
until you're endlessly,
you know, everyone,
it always ends in the debate
about driver's licenses
or something like that.
What is a libertarian to you?
- I say libertarian is
somebody who's on your side
and not the side
of the politicians,
the bureaucrats, the lobbyists
and the special interests.
And I tell people that, you
know, best what's best for you
and not the people in
Washington pure and simple.
You should be able to make
your decisions about education,
healthcare,
retirement,
all of the things that are
going through the government
you should be able to make
your own decision about.
- Yeah, do you ever think that
in a weird way, sort of I guess
in a depressing way somehow
that the ship has sailed,
that explaining to people why
government shouldn't be involved
or why you should keep
more of what you've earned
or all of these things that
it's sort of what we
talked about earlier,
but intellectually they get it
but it's sort of like they
can't even fathom a life
where the government wouldn't
do all of these things.
- Well, you know, I was
disheartened for awhile.
However, with COVID
I'm seeing that,
no, we haven't lost
our individualism.
I was so ecstatic
to see those people
storming around the
Michigan state house
saying, hey, we're the land
of the free home of the brave,
you can't lock us up like this.
Or to see the Dallas hairdresser
or to see what even
the shots we've seen
of Nancy Pelosi
being a hypocrite.
I think people are finally
saying, hey, wait a minute.
This isn't what America's
supposed to be about.
And so I think they're now
feeling, you know, libertarians
you know, people like me who
joined the party decades ago
we've always had this
yearning to have freedom
and to have more
liberty in our lives.
But I think the average person
probably didn't feel it.
They didn't feel big government
upon them until recently.
And they're being told
they have to wear a mask
wherever they go
and they're being told, nope,
you're under house arrest.
You gotta stay home,
you can't go to your job
and people I think are
beginning to question it.
- Yeah, so what is the proper
libertarian response to COVID
and lock downs and
everything else,
if you were president, right?
Or no, if you were
president in February
and if you were
president or right now,
what would be different?
- Well, the biggest
mistake that Trump made
was he didn't get the
FDA out of the way.
And again, when people ask me
why I'm running for president
is because government is too big
too bossy, too
nosy, too intrusive.
And the worst part is they hurt
the very people
they're trying to help.
The FDA is an excellent
example of that.
That with the FDA, there
were dozens of testing kits
that we could have had,
but the FDA blocked them.
Originally, we were only
allowed to have two of them.
So meanwhile Southeast Asia,
they're doing extensive testing
seeing who needs to stay home
and who can go out and work.
In the meantime, we're
shutting down our economy.
And on top of that, we had
Trump up on stage
with Dr. Fauci saying,
you know what if you
don't have symptoms,
no need to get tested.
Well, at the very
time he said that
they knew that over
half the people
or at least that was
the wisdom at the time,
that over half the people
who had the virus had
no symptoms at all.
So no that's the time
you need to have testing
when you don't know
if you have it or not.
- And what about the
lockdown specifically?
- Yes, well,
about the testing specifically
that we basically, they
were locking us down
because they didn't know
who would be healthy enough
to be out on the streets.
So how about testing us,
letting us test ourselves
and then we would know.
And here's the irony
from my part is
one of my grandfathers
is from Sweden
and his family immigrated
here to have freedom,
to have the freedom that
they didn't have in Sweden.
And yet Sweden's
stores and shopping malls
and restaurants and
schools all stayed open.
So they're able to
move around freely.
Meanwhile, we supposedly
the land of the free
that people immigrate
to for freedom.
We're all under house arrest.
So that's just a travesty.
So it's just rather
ironic that my family
came here for freedom
and that the old country
was giving them more freedom
at least in this regard.
- Right, so would you
have left the decisions
about lockdowns up to the States
because in effect that's what
Trump basically has done.
I assume that you're
okay with that, right?
You wouldn't have wanted
this to be a federal mandate.
- Well, again, actions
speak louder than words.
Trump was encouraging
the States to lock down.
I think the governors
were following his lead
because the president is
in a role of leadership.
And I think they were only
doing what he wanted them to do.
So now he's saying open back up,
yeah, but you already
told us to close down.
So he shouldn't have given
that message to begin with.
And what frustrates me
is it's one more example
where people are thinking that
they only have one decision,
that we should all vote
and have one decision.
And you know, people are
under the mistaken impression
that if the government
doesn't tell us to wear masks
we're not going to wear masks.
And Walmart shot that down.
Walmart has a policy where
you have to wear a mask
if you're, if you work there,
if you're a vendor, if
you're a shopper, whoever
you have to wear a
mask and Walmart.
So why can't we have a world
in which we vote with our
feet or vote with our dollars.
If we wanna wear a mask,
then we go to Walmart.
And if we don't want to wear
masks, we go to other stores.
Why can't we have that?
And it's really frustrating
because on my local news show,
my mayor of the
city where I live
required, started
requiring a mask
for all grocery stores
and drug stores.
And so they do the man
on the street, you know
interview asking, do you think
we should all have our masks?
And sure, some
people were saying,
yes, that's a good idea.
Other people were saying no.
And it was frustrating
that nobody said,
well, wait a minute
how come we all have to
follow the same rule?
And that's what I
try to get across
the idea with libertarians is
how about we each do
what we want to do?
And we don't need the government
telling us to wear masks.
There are plenty of people
who'd wear masks anyway.
- Right, so I'm
with you on that,
that it can be up to the store,
it can be up to the restaurant
and they can figure
out whatever policies,
if they want people
to wear masks
or they want people to
take their temperature
or whatever it might be.
I'm actually completely
onboard of that.
What would your counter
argument be then
to the people who would say,
Oh, well, if you leave it
just up to the individuals
that people are gonna
do whatever they want
and that then will
cause more of a spread.
- Well, again, you don't
have to go outside.
For instance, my mother
was in the high risk group.
And so she just didn't
go to the grocery store
and her friends went for her.
So there's no rule saying
that you have to go outside
and go shopping or go anywhere.
So I would say that, you know,
nobody's putting
a gun to your head
and asking you to
walk the streets
or going into specific
grocery stores.
And also again, that's
just giving the impression
that we're too stupid to
do anything on our own.
And if you look, there
was a survey that was done
sometime maybe around
April or early May,
where when some of the places
were starting to open up
and they ask people,
do you think we're
opening up too early?
And the polls showed
that something like 70%
of the people thought that
we were opening up too early.
So it just shows that
even in a free market,
people would be a little leery
and would be taken precautions.
- Yeah, all right,
let's move off COVID
and talk about the other
big thing that's
happening at the moment.
Obviously there are the protests
and the riots and Antifa
and Black Lives Matter
and the rest of it.
A couple of weeks ago,
you sent out a tweet
that seemed to support
the Black Lives Matter
Movement specifically
and I know you got a
lot of pushback on that.
Can you just sort of lay
out what you were tweeting?
And then, I don't know, you
didn't quite walk it back
but there was a little bit of
an exchange about it, yeah.
- Yeah, it was a type
off from a staff member
who had capitalized Black Lives
Matter as in the movement,
as in the Marxist group.
Now let me point out that
not all of the people who
are marching out there
with Black Lives Matter
are part of the
national Marxist party.
And of course, you know,
libertarian would be
the opposite of Marxist.
However, if you look, we
share so many concerns.
we share, you know, the police,
the qualified immunity, right?
No knock raids, the
racist war on drugs.
So there are all these
things all of these problems
that we agree with them on,
the problem is we see
a different solution.
They want to go
for more government
whereas we see less
government is the answer.
And I was able to meet
with a local Black
Lives Matter leader
who, again, nothing to
do with the major group
and I spent the
whole day with him
and I sat down and explained
the free market to him.
And by the way, he's
a black preacher,
he had previously been in
prison and we had a great talk
and he said, yeah, this
makes a lot of sense.
And the one thing he didn't know
and this is the message that
I've been trying to get out
is for instance, we all heard
about Rosa Parks, right?
The heroic black woman
who refused to sit on
the back of the bus.
Well, what they're
not telling you
is that that was a government
run government owned bus.
And that at the time 60% of
the bus ridership were blacks.
So if you look at on a free
market like today with Uber
what if Uber were
to discriminate
against the best 60%
of their customers?
They would go bankrupt
as well, they should.
And I explained this
to him and he said,
"Wow, no, I didn't know
that was a government bus.
And yeah, you're right, they
would go out of business."
And so when I explained
how government
had no accountability,
he said yes, that
makes a lot of sense.
And so if we can, you know,
back to kind of the educate him.
If we can kind of
show to these people,
look, you're going
to the very people
who are causing these problems,
maybe we can get somewhere.
- Yeah, it is
interesting because
some of the stuff
that's overlapping,
I always find that the lefties
or the Marxist progressives,
they always say, okay,
we've got a problem
with the government and our
solution is more government
and the libertarians say,
okay, we got a problem
and our solution
is less government,
it's hard to get them
to understand that.
But if you can,
I think that that's probably
the inroads for you guys.
I'm curious with that in mind,
yeah, with that in mind,
where do you stand on the
1964 Civil Rights Act?
'Cause I've had some interesting
debates with libertarians
on whether it should
have been passed or not.
And then if you say, no, it
shouldn't have been passed,
immediately, of course
you're called a racist
but there are some limited
government principles
that I think do make sense
as to why you wouldn't pass it.
Usually it ends up
with everyone saying,
okay, well, we just
shouldn't relitigate it.
- Yes, so I have no problem
with it being passed
when it was passed.
Keep in mind, this was
shortly after Rosa Parks
and so there was systemic
racism in government.
There still is.
And so if government is the
problem, then yes of course
we should have rules
that government fixes it.
However, I would
say that right now,
the free market can
do a much better job
than the government.
What they should have done
was they should have had sunset
laws or something like that.
Because keep in mind
what happened was
immediately after
they freed the slaves,
the blacks were doing great.
There were skilled craftsmen.
They were offering
their services
at a lower price to get
their foot in the door,
which by the way
that's what I did
when I started my own business.
You know, hey, try me out,
I'll give you a lower price.
And so they were
wildly successful.
And so the whites, what they
did was instead of saying,
how can we compete with them?
I guess maybe we should
lower our prices too.
They said, no, what
laws can we pass?
And so they started passing
these laws to where,
you know, you can't
be a woodcarver
if you can't read at a
fourth grade level, whatever.
So it was through the
power of the government
that we got here.
So that's the only reason why
I don't mind the
1964 Civil Rights Act
because it was, because
government was a problem.
So government needed to fix it.
And I've gotten criticized
for bringing this example up
but the thing is you can be
for or you can be against it,
but that's what the free
market is all about.
Sometimes we don't like
what the free market does,
sometimes we do.
But you may have
heard of the case
where this woman who worked
for this large company
put all lives matter on her
Facebook and she was fired.
And the key here was she wasn't,
you know, it wasn't
a company Facebook
and she wasn't discriminating
against an employee,
a subordinate, customer,
vendor, anybody.
Completely outside
and yet she was fired.
So this shows me that
the tide is turning
and the free market
can handle this
better than the government
because we've got the
profit motive involved.
Now a lot of people said,
well, that's not what we mean.
Well, you know,
sometimes you don't like
what the free market does
but it's society showing
where its values are.
And I think society's
values have come a long way
and I think that the average
American has much better values
and much less
discriminatory behavior
than the government does.
- Well, I always find
it funny when people say
if you rolled back
some of these laws,
if you got the government
out of the way,
that suddenly people
would be opening up
white-only restaurants
and it's like, well, most
people that open restaurants
I'm pretty sure it's 'cause
they wanna serve food.
It's not because they're
racist and if it was,
if there was a whites-only
racist restaurant
I'm pretty sure you
wouldn't go there
and the market would crush it.
So I'm with you on that.
But you did say one thing
that I do wanna clarify
so I understand
why you were saying
that there was systemic racism
meaning that the South
had Jim Crow laws
and the government could
come in and fix that.
But you said is, or is currently
that there is currently
systemic racism.
I don't wanna put
words in your mouth.
So can you describe,
well, actually first
can you just define what
you mean by systemic racism
and then give me an example
of what it is today?
'cause I think the definition
is where people get lost.
- Yes, systemic,
built in the system,
hence the word system.
So if you look at the
laws, let's say drug use.
Right now
whites and people of color use
drugs at about the same rate.
And yet six times as
many blacks especially,
you know, looking
at people of color
are arrested and
charged than whites.
And you might say well,
maybe that's just,
they just happen to be there
but, you know, that
raises another question.
But the other thing is if you
look at drugs that whites use
compared to drugs that
people of color use,
the drugs that people
of color tend to use
have longer prison sentences.
So
and if you look at
the prison population
with nonviolent, you
know, with, you know
victimless crimes, which
shouldn't be a crime at all
you'll see that
they actually are
charged more in victimless
crimes than are whites.
- Right, so I think the part
that confuses
people here is that
systemic, I think when someone
says systemic racism to me,
that means that there are laws
that are in place
that are racist.
So as far as I know
there are no laws
that are in place
that are racist.
I think you're talking about
the sort of second order
of there may be more
policing in certain areas
because there's more crime.
So then and then I think what
a lot of people would say
well, that has more to
do with the breakdown
of the black family
and why that happened.
Something like that.
- Right, well, first of all,
to me systemic can
still be part of the,
you know the, an
organization, the environment.
So
if
cops are
out there arresting people
of color at a higher rate,
because that's either
what they're rewarded for,
or that's the hidden message
or they're just outright told
you need to go out to this
neighborhood more often
then that's still systemic,
even if it's not written.
But like I said, there are
written laws for penalties
so that drugs that
people of color use
have longer prison sentences.
So that's actually in the law.
- Yeah, do you know
of any of those
that are still on the books?
I mean, I know that
in New York city,
they used to have
the law about crack
got a higher
sentence than cocaine
and it was generally thought
that more black people use
crack 'cause it was easy.
It was cheaper to get
but I know New York
city got rid of that.
Are there still laws like that?
- Oh yeah and in
fact I did check with
one of my respected friends
at Cato to just check in,
I think about three,
yeah, maybe about three
or four weeks ago.
And I said, okay,
just wanna make sure
that all of these
laws we were talking
about before with
the prison sentences.
And so and he said, yeah,
so I didn't go into detail
just because there
were so many of them
and yes, crack cocaine is
one example then crack.
And of course now we
get into the drug war
and I can't, I have
to at least point out
that Milton Friedman told
us that crack cocaine
would have never been invented
had cocaine not been legal.
It's only because
cocaine was illegal
that crack cocaine
was even invented
just like during prohibition,
people drank less wine and beer
and then went to liquor because
it was easier to smuggle
because it was more powerful.
So
and so I've mentioned
the racist war on drugs
and people wondered
what I mean by that.
Again, we go right back
to the war on drugs
is hurting everybody, of course.
But, especially with the
uneven prison sentences, yes.
- Yeah, so it's interesting
because I think what it
sort of whittles down,
I think a lot of my
audience is gonna say
the way you're defining
systemic racism
is a little different than
the way they define it
which is why I
asked that question.
Because there
aren't specific laws
or if there was a
specific police department
that said arrest more, you
know, arrest more black people
that's in our code of conduct
then of course that is wrong.
But if the question is,
Oh, there happens
to be more policing
in an area that has more crime
and there happen to be
more black people there,
well then we have to
figure out why that is.
I think most people
bring that again
to the welfare state and
the breakdown of the family
and the welfare state is
very much a lefty policy.
Certainly not a
libertarian policy.
- Right, absolutely.
But, well, let me just say that,
I agree with your
listeners, your viewers,
that yes, the free
market can handle
these problems that we've
had with discrimination
much better than the government.
And that now what we have is
we're discriminating
against Asians
trying to get into Harvard
and go right down the line.
It's gotten completely out of
hand and I completely agree.
- Yeah, so on the
drug part of this,
I find this to be a
really interesting one
because, you know, I
always describe myself
as a classical liberal
and people always say,
well, Dave you sound
like a libertarian,
what is a classical liberal?
And I always say, well, look,
a classical liberal in
effect is what I would say
a really sort of a
realist libertarian is
meaning that I love all
the libertarian ideas
but I understand I
can't win all the time
and I'm gonna have to put
some guard rails there.
That's the most simplest way
that I would describe it.
So in my book, I talk
about the drug war
and I'm for
legalizing marijuana.
I'm certainly for legalizing
psychedelics
and then we can whittle
down every little drug,
but I'm not personally
for legalizing
the seriously hardcore stuff.
And it's not because I
wanna put people in jail
because of their decisions.
But the simple truth is
I know that if someone
was cooking meth
next door to me,
I know that there's
gonna be more crime.
And I know that it's going
to be riskier to be out there
and you don't want kids
there and the rest of it.
So are you for legalizing
absolutely everything
with no regulations
or is this a place
where you you find
some middle ground,
I know you would kick it
to the States regardless,
but where do you fall on this?
- Yeah, I mean, yeah,
the States right now
have laws on drinking
and I was appalled when
I moved from a state that
you know, you could drink
pretty much anytime you want
and then I moved to the South
and I was shocked
when I found out,
what, you can't buy
alcohol on Sunday.
You know, what kind of,
why did I end up here?
And in fact, we couldn't
buy alcohol on Sunday
until pretty recently.
So you know, yes, even though
I don't like those laws,
at least there's some
competition among laws,
unless you get the federal
government involved.
And by the way I realized
I'm gonna kind of
leave the topic
for just a minute,
just to explain real quick
because a lot of
people don't know that,
you know, we had,
when I was in school,
in fact, I was a
bartender in college
because I was in a state
where the drinking
age was on the 18.
And that's the way
it was back then.
The different States had
different drinking ages
until Elizabeth
Dole Transportation
Secretary in the 90's
came along, took in, you know,
just like government
always does,
federal government always does
takes in the money
and then dangles the highway
funds in front of States
and says, hey, you want
your highway money back?
You're gonna have to
raise the drinking age.
Now we can have it as bait.
You know, maybe 21 is a
better drinking age, whatever.
But the point is,
it shouldn't be the federal
government deciding that,
it should be the States.
So when I say, okay,
let's have the States
you know, we'll let the States
regulate it if they like,
I mean, really let
them regulate it
not have the federal
government, you know,
backdoor in there trying to
hold bribes over their heads
so they can do what they want.
So really...
- So you'd let them do it?
- (indistinct)
confused what you said
because you said that
you wouldn't legalize
the harder drugs
but then you talked about,
you know, having somebody
having a meth lab,
I mean, I guess is a
meth lab, a harder drug?
I'm confused.
- Yeah, well, meaning
I wouldn't want
if meth was totally legal,
then I suspect that more
meth labs would be popping up
and I know that right now,
if someone moved in next door
and was cooking meth next to me,
while we know it's it's illegal
and someone will hopefully
do something about it,
assuming we still have
a police department here
in Los Angeles, I'm not sure.
but if it was legal,
there would be no recourse
and we know what will happen.
Crime will expand,
you'll get shady
or people around,
your property value
will go down, etc.
- Well I see it
completely differently
because we've got alcohol.
Well, alcohol is legal
and I just don't hear
of many people
making bathtub gin,
but that's part of the problem
is when you legalize
something or decriminalize it
however you wanna do it is
it has to truly be legal.
So for instance, in California,
they've legalized marijuana
but they've limited the
number of people can sell it.
They've got all
these licensing laws
you've got to pay
all these fees.
So there's still an
underground market.
There's still people
selling marijuana illegally.
So that means the
laws aren't right.
Again, when's the
last time you heard
of anybody selling bathtub gin
that would cause
somebody to go blind?
You don't because it's legal
to the point that we go
down and we buy it safely.
So if meth were legal
there wouldn't be people
making it next door.
They'd be making it
down at Philip Morris
or whoever, Seagram's, you know,
whoever makes the other drugs.
- Okay, so I'm not
with you there,
but I do understand
the line of thinking.
That's just fine.
But what would you say?
This is where the conservatives
I think see the libertarian
movement as sort of bananas.
'Cause I think this
is where conservatives
would say, okay, I get freedom.
I get States rights,
I get all that stuff.
But you're telling
me that in effect,
if there was enough
demand for meth,
that Philip Morris and Unilever
should start making meth
if the market demands it
and we know that a society
filled with meth is not great.
So the conservatives
would take sort of,
we want to conserve sort
of a functioning society
where the libertarians
are saying
it's more of a free for all.
Do you think that's like a fair,
it's just sort of like a
philosophically different spot?
- Well, I think
they're misguided.
First off, if you look
where marijuana is legal
you haven't seen increase
in marijuana use,
let's say in teenagers
and you haven't seen
it basically abused.
You know, again, we
look at alcohol...
- But marijuana is
not highly addictive
the way meth or, you
know some opiates,
you know, some of the
more hardcore stuff is.
- Well, alcohol is
highly addictive.
Tobacco's highly addictive.
Those are very highly active.
In fact, our own surgeon
general said that tobacco was,
the former surgeon general,
I believe it was C.
Everett Koop who said that
tobacco was just as a
highly addictive as heroin.
So
and yet that's
legal, but you know,
what we have right now is
we've got drugs being illegal
and so they don't go for help
and even look at where
it starts, you know,
again, when was the
last time you heard
of a liquor store
owner going up and down
the halls of a high
school, trying to sell gin?
If it's legal and the
profits aren't there.
You're not gonna have
the profit motive
for people to go
out and sell it.
Or
I ask when's the last time
you ever heard of a vodka addict
breaking into houses in order
to support a vodka habit?
You know, you can
make enough money
to support it if it's legal.
When things are illegal
they tend to cost 20
to 25 times higher.
So that's 20 to 25
times as many houses
as you have to break into
and so I'm looking at it
and by the way, I'm
not a drug user.
Well, actually I am.
Bourbon is my drug of choice.
(Dave laughing)
Yes, bourbon is a drug
and I got a graduate certificate
in Drug and Alcohol Studies
and I understand that the way
our neuro-transmitters work
alcohol is actually a
very dangerous drug.
Much more dangerous
than marijuana.
But somehow I got
through the 1970s
in high school and college
never having tried marijuana.
I gotta admit, you know,
I'm a goody two shoes
but
the point here is there's
not a profit motive.
You know when people ask
me about legalizing drugs
the point is and they say,
well, but I don't use
drugs so I don't care.
I say, but you should care
if you care about crime.
You should care if your
kids are in a school
'cause right now
there's a profit motive
to get your kids hooked on drugs
and high school kids
themselves will say,
you know, it's a lot
easier to buy marijuana
than it is to buy alcohol.
Yeah, 'cause alcohol is legal,
there's not the profit in there.
There's competition.
It's, we've got the free market
out there taking care of it.
So how about let's
have the free market
take care of the other things
and then if you do
have a heroin problem,
let's treat it as a
medical issue and not,
you know, a criminal issue but,
and also I'm confused
because you said,
well, I'm not, you
want it to remain legal
but you're not for
locking people up.
But isn't that
the definition of,
if it's illegal then you do
lock people up, I'm confused.
- Well, no, I'm with you
on the last part of that,
in that if someone was
addicted to one of the drugs
that I think should be illegal,
say meth or opiates or
something like that,
I wouldn't wanna send
them to jail for that.
I would wanna get them help.
I don't think putting
someone in jail
(indistinct)
Sorry?
- But isn't that what
illegal means that if you...
- Well, when I say illegal,
I was sort of giving
you shorthand on that,
but when I say illegal I mean,
if you're selling it
then there should be
a repercussion for it.
A legal repercussion.
If you're just using it or if
you're mass distributing it
I see that different as
someone that is using it.
And again, this is
just one of those ones
where I find that sort of the,
it's what we're
basically agreeing here
and then there's like
this little space
where it's like
okay, how do you,
there's a more, quite a little
more of a liberal approach,
a little more of a
conservative approach
and a libertarian approach.
And you can remain a good person
and not totally agree on it.
Isn't that crazy?
- Yeah and by the way,
you can think that
every drug should be
legal even though
you've never used them
and Bourbon's your
drug of choice
so again...
- I'm more of a red
wine guy myself.
- Oh, well, you know what, I
do have red wine with dinner.
Yes, if you're a red
wine guy, then good
we're on the same boat.
- Yeah, all right, let's
just keep going through
just sort of the biggest hits
and sort of the big issues.
So foreign policy,
it seems to me
that Trump has been pretty
solid on foreign policy
in that it doesn't seem like
we're going to extra wars.
We've got a couple
of peace agreements
that have been signed in
the last couple of weeks.
He's trying to tell the people,
we shouldn't be in
Afghanistan anymore.
We got some troops out of Iraq.
It doesn't look like we're
gonna be nation building
anytime soon.
Do you see those things
as wins and sort of
what would a purely libertarian
foreign policy look like?
- Yeah, we're in about 160
countries around the world.
I think we were in 160
countries when Trump took office
and I think we're
still in 160 countries.
So if you wanna say
we've made progress
because now we're
in 159 countries.
Well, I don't see
that as much progress.
And we spend more on
military than the next
probably eight
countries combined.
So and it's making us
less safe, not more safe.
That's the worst part about it.
So, no, we need to seriously
bring the troops home
and if I were president
I would turn America into
one giant Switzerland,
armed and neutral in which
we protect our borders.
Yes, we should have borders.
We need to protect them.
However we shouldn't be
protecting the borders
of everybody else.
And I've pointed out, of
course, half facetiously here.
We keep hearing how
isn't France great?
They get five week vacations.
We should get five
weeks vacations.
Well, yeah, maybe if we weren't
paying for their military
we could get five
weeks vacations too.
Why are we paying for
everybody else's military
around the world?
Why should a taxpayer in Alabama
be paying for, you
know, Frances military?
That's absurd.
And I was actually
excited when I heard
that he was bringing,
that Trump was bringing
troops out of Germany.
I thought, oh finally,
a small step, but step
in the right direction
and then I heard he was
putting them in Poland.
No, he needs to keep going.
They need to come all way home.
They need to come to
the United States.
Again, one giant Switzerland.
We need to protect our borders.
- Yeah, so it's interesting
because you've got
obviously some differences
with Trump there, but
when he says things like,
you know, you gotta pay
your share to be a NATO,
you fundamentally agree with
that sort of thing, right?
That the US should not, well...
- I don't think we
should be in NATO.
I thought he didn't like NATO.
I thought he was
gonna get out of NATO.
Isn't that what he was saying?
- I think, well, I think
he was at least saying
that the other countries
have to pay their fair share
or we'd get out and I guess we,
I guess we did at
least cut funding.
I don't know if anyone
made up that funding.
- Well, I got a great way
for the other countries
to pay their fair share.
We get out completely and we
don't pay anybody's fair share.
How's that?
- [Dave] Yeah.
- Problem solved.
- So if we were to have,
you know, strong borders
and a military to protect
the United States itself
do you think we have
any responsibility,
or are there any situations
where there could be a genocide
anywhere else in the world,
or you know, an evil
dictatorial regime
or whatever it might be,
would you see any situation
where we should get involved
to help people that
are not Americans?
- Not from the standpoint
of the government.
Now we had George
Clooney, you know
trying to help people
in war torn Sudan.
We've had, or Syria, I'm sorry.
We've heard of other
people going over
and try to make humanitarian
relief missions.
You know, Americans
are very generous.
They're very helpful.
They want to go over
and help people.
So let's let them help people.
But as far as the US military,
as far as going in,
anytime we go over there
to do something good,
something bad, always happens.
There's always,
you know, they call them
unintended consequences.
Maybe they're unintended
but they're not unforeseen
because anytime you go in
and you pick one
side as the winner,
there's going to be a loser,
who's not going to be
very happy with us.
So I would leave it up
to the very generous
and very fair minded Americans
to do whatever they
like on their own
and keep the military out of it.
- Right, is there an
inherent problem there though
that if this was World War II,
that the United States
would just be sitting
on the sidelines
and that, you know,
the Nazis could have
taken over Europe?
I get, we're not Europe.
I mean, do you see a moral
quandary there at all?
- Well, I'm glad
you brought that up.
Actually many
libertarians think that
we shouldn't have
gotten into the war,
but I'd like to point out
that we were brought into World
War II when Japan bombed us.
So I'd like to make two points.
First of all, many
historians say
that the reason they
bombed us to begin with
was because of unfair tariffs
that we were in a terror for
and secondly,
they, you know, we
look at Japan now.
I mean, look at all the Toyotas
and Hondas we buy from them
they're not going
to bomb us today
because you're
our best customer.
You tend to not bomb
your best customer.
So you say, you know,
when you say foreign policy,
I also include trade in that
and when you look at
what Trump's doing
basically having a
tariff war, with China
I mean, you know, there's a
reason they use the term war.
And I would say we need to
get out of any war with China
that we, there's no way we
can get into a war with China.
We have the ability to
obliterate each other.
We cannot do that.
And the best way to do
that is to open up trade.
So just like, you know,
we buy all these Toyotas
and Hondas from Japan
and they're not gonna bomb us.
How about we do the
same thing for China?
Let's open up the borders.
It's only hurting the citizens.
And of course, I
know you've heard,
you've probably said it where
goods cross borders,
troops don't have to.
So let's go by that model.
- Yeah.
Is there any risk there
that if we just opened
up trade altogether
that they can just
make things cheaper
and that that ultimately
hurts the American worker.
What's the libertarian
answer to that?
I hear that one a lot.
- Yeah, if they
make things cheaper,
then that means the
people in our country
who are poor can afford them.
And it means that we
just sell other things
that we're good at,
that we have a niche at.
And you know, we've been great
and friends since the
entertainment industry,
look at the percentage of
dollars around the world
that are spent on entertainment
that come from our country.
I mean, there's,
you know, this kind of
brings me back to deficit
when people talk about
aren't you worried
about a trade deficit?
So like China, you know,
selling other cheap stuff here.
Well, that's kind
of like asking me,
aren't you afraid that
you have a trade deficit
with where you buy gas?
No, because I buy gasoline
from them, but guess what?
They take my dollars and somehow
they come around back to me.
So we can
look in
at each thing in isolation
and I'm the opposite
of an isolationist.
I think we need to
be good neighbors
to everybody around the world,
both economically
and militarily.
And here's one example
where freedom works
and freedom is morally right.
Where we can trade
peacefully and prevent wars.
- Yeah, so we focused
obviously more on Trump
because he's the president
and policies of
the conservatives.
What do you make about
what's going on with
the democrats right now
and what seems to be a
war between the younger
progressive lefties versus
a little bit I guess,
of what's left of the old guard.
There ain't much left and I
think it's sort of summed up by,
it's summed up by Biden.
What do you make about
what's going on there?
- Well but the old
guard is still strong
and the thing that
I've been pointing out,
is how they muzzled
Tulsi Gabbard,
how they unfairly kept
her out of the debates.
And what's such a shame is
that the democratic party
used to be the party of peace.
They used be the antiwar party
and they've got a
great antiwar candidate
Tulsi Gabbard, by the way
let me clarify that and say
great on that position.
I mean, I realized,
yes, she's socialist
on the economic issues
and that's why I
wouldn't vote for her
that's why I'm running
for president, excuse me.
But on the war
issues, she's great.
And yet the government,
the democratic establishment
kept her out of the debates
'cause they wanted
to quiet her down.
So yeah, the old guard,
there may not be
many of them left,
but they sure are powerful
and that's really a shame.
And that brings me by the way,
just one other quick point is,
you know, I talk about how
the democratic party used
to be the antiwar party.
When I first joined the movement
and people asked me
what libertarian was,
what I would say is, well, we
take the best of both sides.
You know, we take the best
parts about the right,
about the republicans, we
believe in economic freedoms
and we take the
best about the left,
that were antiwar,
that we believe in
individual liberty.
And now I can't say that anymore
because democrats aren't
acting like democrats
and republicans aren't
acting like republicans.
And maybe it was coincidence
that they even agreed with us.
And young people are
shocked when I tell them
that as recently as 2012,
Barack Obama and Hillary Clinton
both were against gay marriage.
Meanwhile, the libertarian
party was for individual rights.
You know, they were advocating
gay marriage in 1972.
I hate to say
advocating the rights
you know, not that
everybody should do it
but advocating (indistinct)
whereas Democrats...
- That's a whole different
that sounds far more
authoritarian (indistinct)
- Yeah, the people at the top,
you know, of the
democratic party
they're saying gay
marriage should be illegal.
And if you don't mind
let me bring in one other
free market item here.
The Disney company in the
early 90's, 20 years earlier
we're giving benefits to
partners of their gay employees.
So once again, we've
got the free market
looking out for the individuals
because they have
to make a profit.
They wanna hire
the best employees
so they've got to
basically put in, you know,
about a peer pressure.
So and you know, going back
to racist and all those laws
again the free market can
do such a much better job
than the government at anything.
- What do you make about
what's going on with Biden?
Do you think
something's wrong there?
- Well, I'm not a
clinical psychologist,
but even if I were,
I think there's some law
that would keep me
from diagnosing him.
But my answer is,
it doesn't,
what concerns me is what he
was saying 10, 20 years ago.
I mean, what he was
saying 10, 20 years ago
as a younger man,
that made absolutely no sense.
What worries me is,
you know, how he
thought the crime bill
was such a good thing
to pass in the 90's.
So people are saying, well,
maybe he's not all with it now.
I would suggest he wasn't
with it 20 or 30 years ago.
- All right, I got
one more for you.
I'm gonna toss you a softball
here and just tell you that.
As I think you know,
I have a lot of disaffected
liberals that watch this show.
I have a lot of
what I would call
sort of new school conservatives
and even old school
conservatives.
But I would say
generally at this point,
my audience leans
probably center, right?
Jo Jorgensen make
your make your pitch
for why they should vote for you
on November 4th.
- I would say I understand
why you voted for Trump
to the conservatives in 2016.
He came in as an outsider,
he said he was going
to cut the budget.
He was going to cut spending.
He said he was a businessman
who knew how to get things done
and he would bring
the troops home,
but he didn't do any of that.
And I would say
to the Democrats,
you know again,
the democratic party
has traditionally
been the party of peace.
They shut down Tulsi Gabbard,
they shut down Bernie Sanders.
Basically, you've got a very
slick party machine going on
that gave you Joe Biden, even
though you don't want him,
if you really want an outsider
then please check me
out and go to jo20.com.
That's jo20.com
and I think you'll
see that we are really
what you believe in.
We are the ones giving
you what you want.
And I'm so excited
to announce that
something like 75%
of our volunteers
are from outside the
party because they realize
that they're just not,
that the two old parties
just aren't giving
them what they want.
- All right, I thank
you for your time.
I'm glad we were
finally able to do this
and good luck the
rest of the way.
- Well, can I ask you
one quick question?
- Sure.
- So you voted for Gary
Johnson, have I won your vote?
(Dave laughing)
- That's good, Jo.
Listen, I am so frustrated
by
what is happening with the left
and the destruction
of our institutions,
academic, media institutions,
everything else.
And I, at this point,
I see Trump as the
bulwark against that,
the ideas that
you've laid out here
for the little marginal
differences we have
I think are the right ideas.
My audience knows that.
I say that all the time.
I don't think this
time that I can vote
for a third party
to be totally honest
and I get you hear a lot of that
and I think you can
probably hear it in my voice
that it's not the way I sort of
wanna go in a certain regard,
but I think Trump
has done enough
on the big things
that I care about,
but I'll be happy to discuss
this with you privately,
maybe the day
before the election.
How about that?
- Can I make one last
plea to your viewers?
- Yeah.
- Which is many of you live
in a solidly red
state like I do.
You know, we were one of only
six States to carry Bob Dole.
Your state's going to
carry Donald Trump anyway,
the red States are going
to give Donald Trump
the electoral college votes.
If you want to send
a message to Trump,
that you don't like that he's
gotten new bigger government,
vote for me
because Trump's gonna get
the electoral votes anyway?
If you live in a solidly
blue state like California,
Joe Biden's gonna get it.
If you're not happy with
what your candidate is doing,
then vote for me
because in the solid red
and solid blue States
it's not gonna make
much of a difference.
So let's send some
kind of message.
- You know what, Jo, that
is totally in line with
what I was saying four years ago
and that's why I was
fighting for J. Gary Johnson
to get into the debates
because my thought was,
okay if the libertarian
isn't gonna win,
let's just,
you know, if that's just
not realistic at the moment,
I'm talking four years ago
then at least let's get
these ideas out there.
It starts with ideas
and if that's a policy
or if that's an idea
that can get you
to cede some of these
good ideas out there,
ideologically I'm
totally with you.
- Okay, well, thanks so much.
I hope to be on your show again
(all laughing)
- I enjoyed it and good luck
and we'll talk again, thanks.
- Thanks so much,
have a great time.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
checkout our politics playlist
and if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlists all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.